for the second night in a row fans were
treated to a concert at the draft
experience tonight ice cube taken the
stage that show just wrapping up
victoria saha was there and has more on
this entertaining evening victoria
hey guys if you thought yesterday was
busy today was even busier as teams
finished with their final picks leaving
fans to celebrate all evening long
as the last pick was announced the crowd
went nuts welcoming rapper ice cube on
stage the rapper brought in a whole new
level of excitement for the nfl draft
experience although for some spending
the whole day here was tiring many say
they are taking in every minute
or not they're your friends yes yes good
experience everybody's getting along
it's great it's very positive it's
amazing growing up in vegas my whole
life i was always running a team an
arena all of that and to finally have
something this big and this massive is
so exciting hundreds of thousands of
fans filled up the area by the link in
fact we saw a sign earlier that says
this area reached maximum capacity and
no one knew will be entered in
the fund continues tomorrow for day
three as marshmallow takes the stage in
the evening the draft experience is open
eight to six now remember this whole
experience is absolutely free all you
need to do is download the nfl one pass
to enter victoria saha live local now